it's just been this magical thing that  occurred this kind of really risky idea  bringing this whole world to life and I  think with Thor yet Hemsworth in front  and there was this very kind of little  sci-fi version of a Marvel picture  Canadian film has grown a great  affection for Earth and humans and the  first time we saw him when he was  arrogant that can be this great kind of  strength and knowledge and power with  him but there's also a sort of naive  kind of kid there at the center of it  it's nice to have that contrast and that  mix biggest concern is that their  well-being of this world and he very  much is sort of looking out further into  the universe to make sure that threat  doesn't consume this world as well